[Music]
hi and welcome to episode number 194 of
the weekly Google cloud platform podcast
I'm Asha and I'm here with my colleague
John hey John hey how's it going pretty
good yourself pretty good I'm pretty
happy to finally be done at PAX it was a
really great experience and I got to see
you yeah we did get to hang out here in
Seattle and enjoy a brief Seattle summer
day together and the new office is
pretty a new Google cloud office in
Seattle is a plus it is amazing so this
week on the podcast we're gonna be
talking to one of our fellow developer
advocates working on cloud dale and
we're gonna be talking more about ml
sounds cold dale is a really really
great friend of mine sad to see her go
cuz she's moved on from the New York
office to another office but we did
share one last moment and it was pretty
good
yay lemon later after our interview with
Dale we will have a question of the week
about containers because everyone's
excited about containers but first cool
thing of the week
[Applause]
you've actually got more cool things
this week than I do John so why don't
you start the first thing is a blog post
written by Simon zeltser a dpe on the
cloud team and it is about building a
development workflow for a cloud code on
a pixel book and I found this blog post
really well because when I'm teaching my
students and they are working with pixel
books it's very hard to set up an
environment for software development on
a pixel book but this blog post goes
into depth about how to set up the
environment get started with visual code
get started with cloud code and also he
also takes a step into setting up
containers and working with a docker and
everything so it's pretty cool and
pretty awesome that sounds cool I have
been meaning to spend more time with
cloud codes I will totally check that
out my cool thing of the week is an
article I ran across yesterday on
Twitter the article itself is on medium
and it will be linked in our show notes
but it's about how the ideas of agile
are actually ideas that feminism and
civil rights movement in the progressive
movement and other movements have been
pushing for years and years around
iterating failing fast cooperation
seeking to hear all voices and I found
it really educational because it tied
together some stuff that had been
banging around in my head apparently for
the last year because I woke up this
morning the social media has reminded me
that I actually wrote the social media
post about this exact same issue exactly
one year ago today so clearly this has
been on my mind for a while but the
author of this blog post is it much
better than I ever will and so I
recommend checking out the show notes in
Green giving a read that sounds awesome
it's very interesting to see the
similarities between agile and feminism
so I'm kind of curious what that really
is about so I'll probably give it a
really good read
I recommend it do you have any more cool
things for us this week I do so
considering that this is an m/l episode
ale I decided to pick up something for
about the AI hub and they have a new web
page and improved collaboration features
which is really awesome because it
allows you to as soon as you land on a
page you get to see a lot of commonly
used models and things that you can
share with people on social media they
can be publicly accessible to everyone
so the AOL hub is doing really really
great things so if you are really big
into ml then give it a look that sounds
and it is a lovely segue into our
interview with Dale or we're gonna talk
about NLP translate practicing AI and
kind of how AI fits into the bigger
world looking forward to sharing all
that with y'all all right so let's give
Dale the spotlight and let's go to our
episode
[Music]
so in this episode of the Google podcast
we are hanging out with Dale Markowitz
who is an awesome awesome teammate of
ours and developer relations so Dale
would you like to introduce yourself hi
I'm down I'm an applied AI engineer and
developer advocate and I work on all of
the tools in Google cloud that have to
do with machine learning and words like
natural language processing translation
speech stuff like that awesome and came
to us a little bit about what you do
let's see I do lots of things so I work
with engineers internal and external to
Google to help them understand how they
can use machine learning how they can
use natural language processing I also
spend a lot of time with engineers that
don't have a background in data science
to help them understand how they can use
machine learning and how they can
understand how well a model is
performing and what's an applicable use
case so yeah that sounds pretty
interesting that you work with people
with no background on data science
because well a lot of people probably
have known that our job as developer
advocates are to communicate for our
developers externally and internally
meaning that we talk to our internal
teams and we speak externally to
developers about Conal features but you
speak with people that have no
background in data science so that's
kind of interesting because you're
technically advocating for ml as opposed
to our products so it's kind of
interesting so can you tell us how
someone who doesn't have a background in
ml would probably get started in your
opinion or go about getting into
learning about M oh yeah it's kind of
interesting because I don't know that my
job could have existed five years ago
because back then like for example when
I first started learning about machine
learning there was a pretty high barrier
to entry and you had to be a programmer
to get started but you also had to have
a good understanding of data science and
just the tools that were available to
you five years ago I think we're pretty
rough for new developers like for
example I think tensorflow came out in
2015 so this is a tool for building and
neural networks it's a really popular
tool for building neural networks today
but back when it came out it was really
tough to get started with because you
had to understand how to program you had
to understand how neural networks worked
at a pretty low level but you also had
to understand distributed compete
because tensorflow itself has this
complicated distributed graph
architecture anyway what I'm trying to
say is it was kind of hard to get
started and machine learning a couple of
years ago but there's been so much
progress today
like for example tensor flow getting a
lot easier to use and more user-friendly
and a lot of the tools that I work with
here at Google really make it so that
you can even build a neural network if
you don't have a data science background
so now we have to start thinking about
okay well now suffer developers that
don't have all the data science training
start building neural nets like what are
their concerns what do they have to be
worried of it's not super cool at the
top of the show actually you said
something about natural language
processing can you give me the five
thousand foot view of what that is sure
natural language processing is a study
of algorithms that deal with processing
text and usually today that means
basically the intersection of machine
learning and text processing so what
kind of things are natural language
processing used for in the real world so
in the world people use natural language
processing for lots of things so one
really common use case is you have lots
of text from your customers posting
about your company on Twitter or filling
out a feedback form about your product
or maybe you have a call center where
people are calling in to ask questions
and you use something like speech to
text to transcribe those call center
transcripts and then you want to analyze
to see what people were talking about so
one common natural language processing
problem is you have a lot of text and we
want to see what topics are being talked
about let's then like topic modeling or
sort a bunch of pieces of text into
categories
another common task you might imagine is
something called sentiment analysis so
this is about what emotions people are
expressing when they write so are people
saying positive things or negative
things about your product on Twitter
that sounds super cool and super
powerful I want to talk a little bit
more about those people that don't have
degrees a little bit and I was kind of
curious we have people who have degrees
in ml and their job is to work with
models but those people without degrees
and they work on our models creating
models is a very wishy-washy subject
because you can create a model that can
be completely biased
how does someone without a degree
create a model that is deemed unbiased
in your opinion that's a good question
because it is true that if you are doing
a normal software engineering task then
not all the time but a lot of the time
you can immediately tell if it's broken
because your program crashes in a really
horrendous way unfortunately with
machine learning you can be working on
something for months and then you put it
into production and you don't even
realize it's broken for a while and it's
broken in a way that is surprising or
that was hard for you to anticipate like
for example all times we want to label
things so we have pictures of dogs and
cats and we want to build a model that
automatically labels them as dogs or
cats so you might think that a really
good model just automates this process
but actually a really good model only
correctly labels to these things most of
the time but all models make mistakes so
this is just a natural thing and when
you're developing first of all you have
to expect this to happen and you have to
make sure that the consequences of your
model making a mistake are not that bad
this is why I hope that most of the
people that I'm talking to that are
trying out machine learning for the
first time are planning on deploying
their models and Nan crucial settings
like that they're not building
navigation systems for airplanes or
analyzing medical scans and then making
life-or-death decisions so first thing I
think is to not choose applications
where the consequences of making mistake
are really deadly then the next thing
that we would tell people is to consider
the different types of errors that a
model can make because they're different
ways model can be wrong for example with
the cats and dogs case you could label a
cat as a dog or a dog as a cat let's say
that we're looking at scans of lungs and
we want to see if we can detect
pneumonia automatically machine learning
is very good at understanding medical
scans actually a lot of models we have
today can even beat human practitioners
but let's say we're doing this task so
the first thing that a model can do is
think it can give you a false positive
so this would mean it looks at a scan of
lungs and it thinks that you have a
pneumonia when you really don't that
error is definitely horrifying but maybe
it's not that bad because it means that
you I don't know spend more money on
scans and doctors only to find out that
you didn't really have a problem but
then there's another type of error
called a false negative where you really
did have pneumonia but the
says that you didn't and that's much
more costly because now you've just
overlooked a potentially
life-threatening or very serious disease
so the next thing for practitioners is
to think about all these different types
of errors and understand what you would
do in each of these different cases so
another way that models can be wrong is
that they can somehow introduce bias and
there are many ways that this can happen
but usually it happens because the
examples that you've shown your model
the training data is in some way biased
so for example my opinion one of the
worst ways that machine learning has
been applied is to something like
predictive policing so you want to
somehow collect data about people and
predict who's likely to commit a crime
or who's likely to recommit a crime the
problem here is that the people that get
pulled over for crimes in the first
place is bias and in fact years and
years of policing has an eight human
bias so if you train a model on that
data you're just going to reflect those
biases the right solution here is to
choose your datasets carefully so that
they reflect all of the different groups
that you can think of that there might
be a difference in performance so let's
say you're training a vision model to
identify people's faces you want to make
sure that your dataset has people of all
different races all different ages sexes
outfits etc and if you're really
concerned about this then you want to
look at how all the model does
specifically on these groups so break
your date into these different groups
and make sure the performance is pretty
similar across all of them there's
something we're really interested in
Google it's something that we're really
spending a lot of time thinking about
how we can make this more clear to the
user and how we can integrate it into
our products so do you have any
guidelines I mean you mentioned looking
at all the ways that it could go wrong
do have any guidelines for folks who are
just getting into machine learning or
aren't necessarily data scientists by
trade but are using some of the products
that make machine learning easier like
what kinds of stuff should they be
thinking about when they're working on
their models sure so when you first
learn machine learning you'll have to
learn how to parse a bunch of different
metrics to just baseline evaluate how
well the model is doing precision and
recall I want to talk about that because
you probably have to read a blog post
and spend a couple of minutes thinking
about it before it really sinks in but
the strongest advice that I have
probably is you have this data that you
use to train a model and then you try to
somehow to
fly it into production to make
predictions on the fly and a lot of
times people get caught up on the data
set that they use to train the model
does it actually reflect the data that
they're making predictions on so maybe I
use a bunch of stock photos to train a
clothing classifier but then when I
actually use my clothing app and people
are taking pictures of themselves well
suddenly those photos look a lot
different than stock photos so that's a
major source of error and also sometimes
the distribution of data can shift so in
the beginning your model works really
well and then style trends change and
suddenly it doesn't recognize that like
two 2's are in or something I would
really advise them on you to play a
model before you let it go into the wild
you watch how it performs on data like
you don't let it make predictions but
you sort of simulate what it predictions
it would make and make sure that you're
ok with those and also understand that
you do have to be continually monitoring
your model because of the fact that you
know the real world could change so it
sounds like when you're using machine
learning you need to constantly be on
top of it to make sure that it's telling
you what you think it's telling you to
make sure it's telling you what you
wanted to be telling you ok so I'm kind
of curious since you have to continue
monitoring it you can't anticipate how
your users are actually going to use
your models how long do you think it
actually takes for you to the word
perfect is going to be you know in air
quotes right now but how long do you
think it takes to create an accepted
fully functioning model it depends on
the task it depends on your standards
for how good it should be working like
for example there's also a lot of
thought around designing interfaces so
that users that are interacting with
machine learning models are aware that
there's going to be some probabilistic
component so I'm kind of curious when do
you think it's actually acceptable to
use mo because you can use ml for a
bunch of things to sell fish and you can
probably use ml to do things that
probably aren't ethical but when do you
find it acceptable to use ml like I said
I think that there are lots of cases
like I wouldn't use machine learning for
anything life-threatening
I wouldn't use machine learning for
anything that determines the fate of
people's lives there are sort of lots of
I think low-hanging tasks that one of my
colleagues described machine learning as
being like kind of a little bit of a
dumb intern
it takes a lot of training and it can
only do very menial tasks but there are
lots of little tasks like that in the
world that have yet to be automated that
it would be great if they were like just
for example journalists they interview
people for stories and they collect
hours and hours of transcripts and they
sit down and they transcribe them so a
journalist's a lot of their time is
spent just literally copying an audio
file to text that's something that we
could do with machine learning and it's
something that I don't think anyone
would complain about as an application
that makes a lot of sense so you
mentioned that you're into natural
language what kind of natural language
tools are available on GCP because I've
played a little bit with some of the
tools trying to detect if one of my
friends was making a pun or not because
he is a very punny human being but I
feel like there's a lot of tools that I
don't even know about so what kinds of
tools do we have around natural language
on GCP so glad you asked with machine
learning it goes sort of like on this
spectrum of easy to get started to
advanced so the easiest tools that you
could use would be something like the
natural language API so this is an API
used like any other the input is text
and it can do things like detect
sentiment detect entities like people's
names places prices dates addresses and
so on can also detect the subject of
text so if you uploaded a New York Times
article about politics it could detect
that from an article about sports and so
on so that's like the easiest entry way
into natural language processing then at
a step I wouldn't say it's harder but
maybe more sophisticated is a tool like
Auto ml natural language it's a tool
that allows you to train your own model
on your own data from scratch and you do
this with a GUI and it's quite easy to
use and there are a bunch of different
models that we can build for text so the
first one is a classification model we
worked with a recipe company and they
wanted to be able to categorize their
recipes into I don't know category like
southern food Mexican food but you could
upload a bunch of recipes have humans
label them and then train a model to do
this automatically
so that's classification you can also
build a custom sentiment model so again
this is about emotions is this piece of
text expressing positive or negative
feelings and within Auto ml you can sort
of fine-tune this
to your own specific data so for example
the natural language API can tell that
if I say I hate oranges that I'm
expressing negative sentiment but if I
said instead there's no legroom in coach
then a model might not know that is a
bad thing because like room is such a
specific niche thing to flying on an
airplane so you might train a custom
model that's more aware of your specific
industry terminology also a new auto ml
feature that was released recently was
custom entity extraction so this is kind
of like classification but you can use
it to identify words within text so for
example you could upload a w-4 and train
a model to extract all of the form
fields that you'd filled out I built a
model to a classified patent so you have
a bunch of patent applications as PDFs
and you identify different fields in the
patent so that's Auto ml and then there
are lots of options for people that are
more sort of savvy with data science so
if you're willing to get dirty with
tensorflow then types of natural
language models you could build are are
endless and we have lots of fun
infrastructure for helping you train and
deploy those models cool so that you
also mention that you work in
translation so is there anything new
that's come about what the translation
API
yeah actually we just recently released
some updates so if you've never used the
translation API it's sort of like Google
Translate but an API format so you can
use our models within your app so the
Translate API works I think very well
however there are some cases where it
doesn't do as great of a job for example
Google Cloud has lots of documentation
online and lots of really specific
terminology like kubernetes or a cloud
run or tensorflow or all of this stuff
that may be a generic translation model
wouldn't have seen before so we have a
couple of features that can help you
improve your translations for this sort
of custom domain one thing if you want
to build a really high quality model is
Auto ml translate so I just talked about
Auto ml natural language but Auto amel
translate allows you to upload lots of
translations that you've done on
whatever your data set is so for example
with the GCP documentation I might
upload English documentation and
Japanese documentation
and then Otto Mel will train a model
that automatically does those
translations that includes this
knowledge it learns from your own
specific data set so this builds very
accurate models but takes a lot of data
to train a model like this but we also
just released a new feature to allow you
to customize your translations just by
using the API and that's this feature
called glossary so the idea is let's say
that I'm going to translate a lots of
things that also mention Google but
there are some words that I know exactly
how I want them to be translated so I
want kubernetes to be translated into
Japanese in this very specific way that
it's not the default way that the
translation API does it the new feature
is called glossary so it allows us to
upload a list of word pairs in one
language than the one you're translating
to so that the API will before it does
any translation just make these one for
one replacements using your preferred
translation and then it will translate
the rest of the sentence that's actually
super powerful because I don't know of
any domain that doesn't have
domain-specific vocabulary or users
words in ways that normal people don't
use words and sometimes you have terms
that need to be translated in very
specific ways so that's super cool I can
imagine a lot of people get use out of
that yeah we actually think about it a
lot for translating our own
documentation best use cases are the
ones that we experienced you sometimes
that's cool so yeah you and I have been
really good friends in the office and
we've been talking about a couple of
things that you've been working on so
you mentioned that you work on this
project click Google News lab so I'm
curious to learn a little bit more about
and I'm pretty sure our listeners are
too so yeah sure so ever since I joined
Google I knew about the Google News lab
and thought it sounded really awesome
it's this team here that works with
newsrooms to help them advance
journalism through technology so they'll
work with different newsrooms and help
them build out technology that helps
with investigative reporting and what I
do with them is I'm sort of like a
machine learning consultant so I'll talk
to newsrooms about how they might use
machine learning in a project or
something like this you have any
examples you can tell us about I'm not
sure I can imagine what that looks like
yeah sure I can tell you about a project
that we just worked
done so I recently finished up working
on a project with a newspaper in Mexico
called El Universal they wanted to
tackle a really complicated issue which
is that in Mexico there is a lot of
homicides and unfortunately some areas
are so dangerous that reporters can't
even cover homicides because they are at
risk in doing so these we call a news
deserts the areas that are sort of too
dangerous to report on so we worked with
this newspaper to build a system that
could identify these places where
stories weren't written on crimes so to
do that Google News has this
comprehensive stream of news stories
written all around the world so we
looked at all of the news stories
written in Mexico and we whittled it
down to stories that were written about
homicides and then we sort of used
machine learning we used auto ml
actually to figure out which of those
stories would be relevant for coverage
so they were talking about a crime
committed on a specific day in a
specific region we were able to sort of
use this to build this map of places
where crimes were being committed but
they weren't being reported about so
it's a pretty heavy sobering subject but
it was neat to be able to help out with
this reporting this seems really
interesting you mentioned that use auto
ml but like specifically what product
can Otomo like NLP translation you know
we use natural language processing API
and auto ml so we use the API to do
things like extract locations mentioned
in news stories and then we used auto ml
to build a classifier that figured out
which articles were relevant for our
reporting verses which weren't you said
that it's heavy but crime reporting is
super super valuable people need to know
what's going on in their neighborhoods
and I wish that this wasn't a product
that was needed but at the same time it
sounds like it's solving a real problem
to ensure that people can get news
relevant to them in spite of what may be
going on around them not super cool hope
so
so we're almost running out of time but
is there anything that we haven't asked
you about that you want to talk about or
that you think our listeners would be
interested in mmm oh yeah actually there
is one thing I want to talk about my
favorite service on GCP that I feel like
is it kind of hidden and people don't
know exists but if you are in much
learning it's super useful tool it's
probably the biggest unblocker it's our
new data labeling service so the hardest
part of machine learning in my opinion
is not learning what a neural network is
or accuracy or all of this stuff it's
actually finding a label dataset that's
appropriate for your task so you can go
I'm kaggle and try to find one that's
suitable but if you want to for example
classify your own company's internal
documents then for training and machine
learning models you need to label those
documents and sometimes you need to
create hundreds or thousands of labeled
examples which means that you need to
employ a lot of interns probably to
accept until now because now you can use
Google's data labeling service you
basically write up a description of how
you want your data labeled you send it
to the service and then in a couple of
days the data comes back labeled by
human beings and it is designed to work
easily with all of our auto ml's so you
can create a dataset and then
immediately plug the output into auto ml
to build a model so that's my favorite
new thing that's awesome really powerful
for folks you may not have the expertise
or experience to go find the data sets
that they need or maybe their data set
is proprietary for some reason or
another that's cool yeah so they're
really quick we like to ask our guests
to tell us something really interesting
or cool that was built using machine
learning or natural language processing
and I'm just curious do you have
anything that you've seen develop build
or something that you've built that you
would like to share with our listeners
lots of little hacks myself like for
example I used Auto ml to predict which
posts would be top posts on reddit
that's a really hard task because you
might imagine but it did a pretty good
job or predict for example like whether
a comment that somebody writes on a
forum is toxic I think my favorite thing
is that once you have a data set it's
very easy to build a model so I'm always
sort of trying to see if I can predict
things we thought of ml that's awesome
because you can imagine a lot of people
going four-arm so they read comments on
like YouTube and you can imagine a lot
of them would probably be deemed like
offensive or something so if you can use
NLP to actually scour the millions of
comments possibly like either a sensor
or even completely erase those type of
comments it builds for a better
community yeah also one of my favorite
things that somebody built is something
that you built John talked about it
I felt something for gamers where they
can speak like they would to other
people in the games and then their
comments will be translated in real
times that people and lots of different
languages can insult each other over the
Internet
I mean collaborate I mean I don't think
it's helping each other is the intended
purpose of that it's been a real fun
project and thanks to your hopefully
it'll be a very big success when I have
a talk about it yeah it's super cool
thank you so much for coming to chat
with us today Dale if folks want to find
out more follow the work you're doing is
there a good way that they can find out
more about your work or follow you on
the Internet
sure I'm always willing to give people
my Twitter handle it's Dale quark like
the subatomic particle yeah and I try to
keep a lot of things on medium so I'll
be there too awesome and will you be
making any appearances anywhere the next
thing that I'm doing that's reasonably
close is I'm going to the Minnesota and
Madison devfests there at the end of
September so if anyone's there make sure
you say hi well thanks for joining us
Dale it's been a pleasure and I can't
wait to see what other cool things you
build with em oh thanks see you John
Nadja thanks Dale for the very very very
in-depth conversation about ml and now
that we're wrapping up we're going to
get into our question of the week
how many different ways can you run a
container on GCP yeah I love this
question John I think we did it a
previous time that I was on the podcast
you're probably more than a year ago but
the answer has changed so by my count
there are at least five ways to run a
container on GCP the obvious one google
kubernetes engine gke also now we have
club run which is another way of running
containers but there are a couple ways
that most people don't know about first
of all App Engine flexible environment
can actually run a container it's based
around containers and so if you have a
container that is an option and compute
engine in and this is the one that even
a lot of Googlers don't know about can
actually start a compute engine VM from
a container image and then the fifth one
is you can always use a VM as a computer
and set up your own either kubernetes
environment or docker environment to run
a container that way not using any of
the managed services so at my bus count
there are at least five ways to run a
container on GCP that's awesome and it's
kind of interesting to see the evolution
of GCP and how it supports containers
cuz how many ways were there about a
year ago would you say my entire time at
Google pretty much we've had four cloud
run is the new one and cloud run is cool
and awesome and now folks should go
check it out awesome so Asia I guess the
next thing is where you're gonna be
where are you traveling to or if you're
doing anything I'm gonna be at home and
I am so very excited to be at home
curled up with my cats and you know
travel schedule is pretty light for the
next couple weeks how about you John
well next week I will be at the internal
Google game summit which should be a lot
of fun and after that I will be
traveling to Montreal for three or four
days to spend time with some really
close friends from school and celebrate
my brother's wedding
which is happening next month awesome I
have been really enjoying watching how
the work at Google around gaming has
become more centralized and becoming a
thing it makes me happy because gaming
is awesome definitely and it's really
good to connect with everybody just talk
about gaming as one and cohesive so it's
gonna be really great to catch up with a
lot of folks have a good time I think
that's it for our episode well thank you
all for listening this week and we hope
to see you next week see Iser
bye John
[Music]